the National Library of Medicine
presents what in the world is arsenic
arsenic in our food this rice is the
best whatever my mom put in it is so
good
lucky you my lunch is so boring my apple
juice is the best part I don't know you
guys think about what you're eating
Caleb I read online that arsenic is in
rice and Gloria I heard it's an apple
juice too you guys could get arsenic
poisoning
I don't know grace I don't think it's
bad tastes pretty delicious to me I
don't know either but let's find out
what's arsenic anyway I remember mr.
best naming it on the periodic table
that's its chemical symbol yeah he said
it was an odorless tasteless element so
how can we tell if it's in our food
chill out Caleb let's first figure out
where arsenic is it's an element on the
periodic table right it's probably found
in the earth water or air like a bunch
of other ones just found a great site
from the National Library of Medicine
called the environmental health student
portal let's see it says arsenic is
found in the Earth's crust air and water
humans also add arsenic to the
environment through farming and mining
people use arsenic in wood preservatives
and pesticides arsenic exists in
different forms pure arsenic is rare
it usually combines with other elements
to form compounds or combinations yeah
organic and inorganic compounds they're
kind of like relationships some are more
toxic than others let me explain with
the chalkboard when arsenic combines
with carbon and hydrogen
it makes organic arsenic compounds which
are less toxic than inorganic ones when
arsenic combines with another element
like oxygen or chlorine it makes
inorganic compounds which are harmful to
human health what
I can't believe I'd never learn these
sciency words for these stuff caleb mr.
best talked about that stuff two hours
ago
sorry I I forgot from two hours ago what
I have a short memory
you guys this doesn't tell me if I
should be worried about what's in my
apple juice is arsenic poisonous or not
my dad loves to
read mystery books some of their plots
have arsenic poisoning
that's not pulled out of thin air it can
be toxic bad things have happened in
real life there was a 19th century
arctic explorer named Charles Francis
Hall he was perfectly healthy until he
drank a cup of coffee one day and died
people thought he died from a disease so
no one suspected foul play until almost
100 years later when a biographer looked
into it the guy discovered that Hall
died from a lot of arsenic in his body
but the arsenic was only present in the
last two weeks of his life people say
his crew murdered him oh that's terrible
I know right arsenic can be fatal but
can also cause other health problems
like cancer skin color changes and small
warts
that's not alarming not at all I see how
that guy's crew put arsenic in his
coffee but how's arsenic in my rice or
glorious apple juice
arsenic is in soil and water right some
of it can make its way to drinking water
and food since rice apples and other
fruits vegetables and grains are grown
in the soil there's a teeny bit of
arsenic in a bunch of food some plants
though like rice take up arsenic from
the soil more readily than others so
we're in trouble huh not exactly the
dose makes the poison
for example aspirin is helpful for minor
pain relief and is pretty safe in small
amounts but toxic in large ones not just
that we're barely exposed to arsenic a
teeny bit is in some food but it's not
like we're mining and around high levels
of it how do you know how much arsenic
is okay have you heard of the
Environmental Protection Agency or EPA
my uncle works there it regulates how
much chemicals are allowed in stuff
let's see what it says about arsenic got
it the EPA allows 10 parts per billion
or ppb of arsenic in drinking water 1
ppb is a sugar cube in an Olympic sized
swimming pool if more arsenic than 10
ppb is found in water special water
treatment methods are used to take
what about for apple juice hold your
horses I'm looking it up spotty Wi-Fi
aha another federal agency called the
Food and Drug Administration or FDA has
been checking out arsenic levels in food
what does it say
the FDA studied 94 samples of arsenic in
apple juice with 95% of them having less
than 10 ppb total arsenic all of these
samples were below 10 ppb for inorganic
arsenic the more toxic kind so I'm good
yeah the FDA is pretty confident that
apple juice is safe for kids and adults
I wonder what it says about rice arsenic
levels in rice have stayed the same over
the past 20 years low meaning you don't
need to change how you eat rice whoo you
know what that means I'm chowing down
it's still good to eat different grains
you don't know my family
hey mom what's for breakfast rice what's
for lunch
rice what's for dinner something
different rice and beans sounds like
your mom I'm glad we figured that out I
love apple juice thanks for looking out
for us grace but relax
I was just wondering I'd seen this
article on the Internet
yeah but you can't believe everything
you read online the sites we looked at
were good especially the environmental
health student portal can it help with
last night's homework I still haven't
done it
do it before lunch ends hold up let me
finish my rice real quick
member